JOB GAINS OR GROWTH FIGURES
GOING FORWARD.
WE'RE LOOKING AT STEADY AND
STABLE GROWTH AND BRINGING
INFLATION DOWN.
>> CERTAINLY, AS THE PRESIDENT
SAYS, INFLATION IS THE NUMBER
ONE DOMESTIC ECONOMIC PROBLEM
FACING THE UNITED STATES RIGHT
NOW.
BUT IT WASN'T JUST THE PRESIDENT
WHO GOT IT WRONG A YEAR OR SO
AGO.
I WANT TO PLAY FOR YOU WHAT YOU
SAID ABOUT INFLATION LAST YEAR.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> IS THERE A RISK OF INFLATION?
I THINK THERE'S A SMALL RISK,
AND I THINK IT'S MANAGEABLE.
I DON'T ANTICIPATE THAT
INFLATION IS GOING TO BE A
PROBLEM.
BUT IT IS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
WATCHING VERY CAREFULLY.
>> WAS IT A MISTAKE, MADAM
SECRETARY, TODOWNPLAY THIS
INFLATION RISK?
DID THAT CONTRIBUTE TO THE
PROBLEMS WE'RE ALL SEEING RIGHT
NOW?
>> WELL, LOOK, I THINK I WAS
WRONG THEN ABOUT THE PATH THAT
INFLATION WOULD TAKE.
AS I MENTIONED, THERE HAVE BEEN
UNANTICIPATED AND LARGE SHOCKS
TO THE ECONOMY THAT HAVE BOOSTED
ENERGY AND FOOD PRICES, AND
SUPPLY BOTTLENECKS THAT HAVE
AFFECTED OUR ECONOMY BADLY, THAT
I DIDN'T AT THE TIME DIDN'T
FULLY UNDERSTAND.
BUT WE RECOGNIZE THAT NOW THE
FEDERAL RESERVE IS TAKING THE
STEPS THAT IT NEEDS TO TAKE.
IT'S UP TO THEM TO DECIDE WHAT
TO DO, AND FOR OUR PART,
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS FOCUSED ON
SUPPLEMENTING WHAT THE FED DOES
WITH ACTIONS WE CAN TAKE TO
LOWER THE COST THAT AMERICANS
FACE FOR IMPORTANT EXPENDITURES
THEY HAVE IN THEIR BUDGETS.
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS IS ONE
EXAMPLE.
HEALTH CARE COSTS, ANOTHER
UTILITY BILLS, IF CONGRESS IS
WILLING TO PASS SOME OF THE
PROPOSALS TO BOOST THE USE OF
NONRENEWABLES.
I THINK THAT CAN SERVE TO BRING
DOWN AN IMPORTANT COST THAT
HOUSEHOLDS FACE.
HE REALIZES, WE ALL REALIZE WHAT
AN IMPORTANT AND HUGE BURDEN
INFLATION IS PLACING ON AMERICAN
HOUSEHOLDS.
>> WE HAVE ALL SEEN THE GAS
PRICES EXPLODE OVER THE PAST
YEAR HERE IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND WHICH IS A REAL, REAL
PROBLEM OBVIOUSLY FOR SO MANY.
LET ME JUST FOLLOW UP.
YOU SAY YOU WERE WRONG IN YOUR
ASSESSMENT OF INFLATION A YEAR
OR SO AGO.
JUST TODAY, THE FORMER U.S.
TREASURY SECRETARY, LARRY
SUMMERS, A MAN YOU KNOW WELL,
SAID THE FEDERAL RESERVE NEEDS
TO DO SOME, QUOTE, CONSIDERABLE
SOUL SEARCHING RIGHT NOW ABOUT
HOW BADLY THEY MISSED THE
GRAVITY OF THE INFLATION
PROBLEM.
IS LARRY SUMMERS RIGHT?
>> LOOK, I'M NOT GOING TO
COMMENT ON THE FED'S POLICIES.
CHAIR POWELL HAS MADE CLEAR THAT
HE HAS EVERY INTENTION AND
BELIEVES AS I WOULD THAT THE FED
HAS THE TOOLS TO BRING INFLATION
DOWN AND THAT'S HIS FOCUS.
YOU KNOW, THE FED HAS A DUAL
MANDATE.
THE ECONOMY IS, I THINK IT'S
FAIR TO SAY, OPERATING AT FULL
EMPLOYMENT, WITH THE STRONGEST
JOB MARKET IN GENERATIONS.
INFLATION IS TOO HIGH, AND IT'S
GOT TO BE BROUGHT DOWN.
>> IS IT GOING TO GET WORSE IN
THE SHORT TERM?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, CORE
INFLATION HAS COME DOWN.
IT'S STILL TOO HIGH, BUT IN
RECENT REPORTS, WE HAVE SEEN IT
MOVE DOWN, AND THAT'S AN
ENCOURAGING SIGN.
BUT OIL PRICES ARE HIGH.
RUSSIA CONTINUES TO WAGE WAR
AGAINST UKRAINE.
WE'RE TRYING AND THE EUROPEANS
ARE TRYING TO ADDRESS THAT AND
LIMIT HIS ABILITY TO WAGE THIS
WAR.
THERE CAN BE IMPACTS ON ENERGY
AND FOOD PRICES THAT, YOU KNOW,
WE CAN DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
DOMESTICALLY TO CONTROL.
THE PRESIDENT HAS AUTHORIZED